s'abonner
ce qui s'est passé
Quoi
nous faisons A c'est notre moyen de transport
En fait, les traîneaux sont nos ancêtres depuis des temps immémoriaux.
nos grands-parents allaient à l'hôpital avec eux.
Maintenant, ils sont allés dans les villages, les districts et les provinces.
Bien sûr, les gens sont curieux
ils s'entendent et nous les aidons
comme je l'ai dit, nous le sommes
s'abonner
IL
J'attends très très Bazar en dessous je
alors Dieu merci, je suis content de l'invention
s'abonner
Oui, c'est pour garder notre culture vivante
Nous continuons
Notre ancienne tradition est l'équitation
jeux de javelot courses de luge
nous faisons tout ce que nous montrons
nous aidons nos invités ici
Sous quelles conditions
nous montrons que nous vivons
J'essaye de survivre